We're all done with the documentary.
I mean, they haven't done the footage and stuff,
they haven't edited it,
but I'm like done hanging out with them.
And it's so funny
because it was just a couple hours over the last two days.
It was a couple hours yesterday and a couple hours today.
But because everything we talked about was some of like
the most deepest parts of my life,
the most painful parts of my life, and, you know, whatever.
It feels like such a connection.
And so I'm like, so sad that they're leaving.
I'm like,
they live in Fucking France.
I don't know the next time I will see these women,
but just this little bit of time was really impactful.
It's really beautiful when a woman supports you and encourages you
and validates you.
And so to have women from across the fucking world say, wow,
I see you, I hear you,
you're not crazy, was like, beautiful.
So I'm gonna miss them.
Now I wanna go to France cause I have friends there.